let G be a twice differentiable function
defined over the closed interval from
negative seven to seven so it includes
those endpoints of the interval this is
the graph of its second derivative G
prime prime so that's the graph right
over there y is equal to G prime prime
of X and they asked us how many
inflection points does the graph of G
have so let's just remind ourselves what
an inflection point is so that is when
we go from being concave downwards to
concave upwards so something like this
and another way to think about it a
point where our slope goes from
decreasing to increasing so here our
slope is that then it's a little lower
but it's a little lower then it's a
little lower but then all of a sudden it
starts increasing again it starts
increasing getting higher higher and
higher so that would be an inflection
point whatever x value where that would
actually happen that would be an
inflection point you could go the other
way around
you could have a function that looks
something like this where we have a
negative slope but then it's our slope
is increasing slope is increasing slope
is increasing but then our slope begins
decreasing again this two would be an
inflection point so in other videos we
go into more of the intuition of how do
you think about the first and second
derivatives of a function at an
inflection point but the big picture at
least for the purposes of this worked
example is to realize when you're
looking at the second derivative you
have an inflection point where the
second derivative crosses the x axis
it's not just it's not enough to just
touch the x axis you must cross the x
axis and so right over here we are
crossing the x axis so that is an
inflection point right over here we are
crossing the x axis so that is an
inflection point here and here we touch
the x axis our second derivative is
equal to zero but we don't cross we
don't cross the actual x axis we don't
go from being positive to negative we go
we stay non-negative this entire time
similarly right over here
maybe something interesting happens past
this point but they're telling us that
the function is only defined over this
interval so actually nothing happens
beyond we getting that points who are
not going to cross the x-axis so to
answer the question how many inflection
points does the graph G have well it has
two inflection points looking at the
second derivative here now we know the
answer why does that make sense why does
you have to cross the Y you have to
cross the x axis well let's just imagine
let's say that this is the graph of a
second derivative so this is F prime
prime so the first derivative for
example could look like this let me the
first derivative might look like this
where over here we have a negative slope
negative slope negative slope negative
slope but it's getting closer and closer
and then right over here all of a sudden
the slope becomes positive and
increasing so that would be F prime of X
and then you could think about well if
this is describing the derivative of our
function then what's our function going
to look like well our function over here
would have a very positive slope but
then the slope would keep decreasing all
the way up until this point and that it
increases again so we have a positive
slope right over here so for example our
function might look like this it might
have a very positive slope but then the
slope keeps decreasing and then right
over here all of a sudden the slope
begins increasing the slope begins
increasing again and so here we were
concave downward over this first part
over this first part we have a positive
slope but it's decreasing positive slope
but it's decreasing and then we go to
having a positive slope but now we are
increasing again and so this should give
you a good sense for why you need to
cross the x-axis in the second
derivative